hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tubulin or not tubulin heading
towards total protein staining as a
loading control in immunological protein
analytical methods
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by protein simple a biotechnic brand
to learn more visit proteinsimple.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our speaker dr christian moritz
researcher institute neuromyogen lyon dr
mouritz you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the kind
introduction
my name is christian moritz i'm at the
university and the hospital of lyon and
san diego as was mentioned already and
i'm very happy to have this chance today
to speak uh to you to all of you with
the title tubulin or not to believe
which this shakespearean idea of this
title came originally from my colleague
thomas schuenberg who i will also
shortly mention in one of the next
slides and yes the subtitle is heading
toward total protein staining as a
loading control in immunological protein
analytical methods main focus western
blood of course
so and
at presentations me for example i always
like to know where speaker is currently
sitting or is coming from and so i'm
currently sitting i go backwards in this
building here and this building is
located in san diego in france
and that's where i'm currently doing my
post doc and also lyon which is a city
next to santigen and it's a
a nice uh little city it's not the most
beautiful city of france but the
the
yeah the ratio of quality of life and
also costs is quite nice here
and
i come originally i did my phd in
germany which is
here where you see it in kaiserslautern
the cities are quite similar both are
um working class cities which nice
people perfect to live
so and also here in kaiserslautern
during my phd thesis in germany it was
where i like to say where the western
plot part of my career began because my
very first paper
it's already some years ago
2013
and was a methodological paper about
western blood and i still remember
asking my
boss at that time eckhart triov if what
he
would think about doing this
methodological paper tried to test
another loading control instead of the
common ones like tubulin or so
and
he was a bit skeptical
about method papers and he said how long
would that take to make to finish and i
said it's i i know which methods i want
to do it would be fast i think we could
do this all in two weeks and of course
you all know how it works
uh things last longer than than you
estimate at the beginning and it lasted
longer but nevertheless i never
regretted to to um have asked him and i
was very happy that he agreed although i
took longer as him
at the end because it became an
important part of
of my career um
i would say i i like to go into the
details of a method and yes it even
ended up today and giving
this presentation which which would not
have happened if i i wouldn't have gone
this first step into some method
improvements
so but i do not want to start with this
publication i would like to start a
little bit more slowly and why not with
the fun fact you might have seen or you
might remember two years ago 2019 there
was the 40th birthday of western
blotting
and i had the chance to write a
scientific birthday toast in the journal
of proteomics and i was also
creating in the top left this uh nice
or funny birthday cake with the candles
to the 40th birthday
and
i was it was quite funny after this
publication
the impact so not the standard the
classical impact factor but more the
social media impact factor was quite
impressive and even higher than for any
of my other research publications or
although i i would say the others are
more important from a scientific view
but here the social media impact was
quite
nice probably also because of this
beautiful cake that i made for western
blood and i want to show you some
um some comments so what were the
comments of the social media community
it was
um the journal of biological chemistry
here on the left who made the tweet
which was even retweeted
91 times
and
other yeah while retreating uh
retweeting other people colleagues
said a bit their opinion about
the western blood and also congratulated
to the birthday like here on the on the
very right
uh sarah chords you see she's describing
the love hate relationship or in the
middle panel
someone is posting a meme of a standard
western plot protocol according to him
which always ends in the crying person
so maybe you find yourself in some of
these descriptions
so
i think yeah it is a cool method we all
love it and hate it
at the same time
and in the 40s birthday
paper i was starting with a quick look
into history and i would like to do the
same i like history and i like science
so why not combining uh the two
so a quick look into the
publications the actual birth of western
blood was in july i think it was the
first july 1979
where this publication here appeared
from the group of george stock and the
west coast of united states california
and what they did for the first time was
the transfer
of proteins which is the actual plotting
step
from
a gel to a paper to a membrane and then
a detection with antisera
which is
interesting maybe not a fun fact is that
the same group just two years before
also
described the northern blot which was a
first pun a first time playing with the
words after edwin southern had invented
the dna
plot and called its southern blotch it
was called southern plot according to
the name of the inventor and then the
rna blot was called northern blot and
yeah and then the western which which
was not mentioned here yet at this in
this moment rexella this was two years
later
but only
two weeks later no it was a bit more
some weeks later in september 79 there
was another group and according to the
authors they did not even know from each
other it was long before twitter it was
long before the pre-publications
um
databases and so it's harry tauben at
all
but you might uh know this name because
he used a buffer the transfer buffer
that is still used and
cited often and here
what is different it's again a transfer
but here for the first time an
electrophoretic transfer he uses sds ura
for the polyacrylamide
electrophoresis he uses
for the first time nitrocellulose
membrane and also primary and secondary
antibody for the protein
detection
then two years later
you see as i wrote in a paper quite
far quite modern for the 80s western
blood has more than two parents so the
third parent is actually the part of
parent who gave the name to the baby
was neil burnett in 81 who used for the
first time at least in a published
version
according to the authors they used on
the word already before
especially as they came from the west
coast and so the word western blood
was
created and i mentioned already
citations funnily the very first
publication is cited cited least of a
free but still an impressive number more
than thousand times
um
tau bennett or at al was assighted uh
most of all more than 60 000 times
incredible probably also because of his
offer is still used
today
and
often cited because of that and burnett
um paper giving the name almost 10 000
times
so
i would like to go on with some
not history now come back today some
more facts and the question is western
bloods are
outdated sometimes
we hear this it i hear i'm i'm also a
part of the proteomics and mars back
community and quite often in this
community i hear people saying
western blood are outdated and some are
complaining that
reviewers are asking of the most backed
data to
to validate the findings with western
plots and they say why western blots is
less exact as mass spectrometry i do not
want to follow this discussion here this
is another topic but here are the
questions if western blots are actually
outdated and
at least i tried to
answer this question regarding the use
and so of course
you could make a poll go to different
labs see how often they use it this is
difficult but we have the publications
we can count how often it is
mentioned
among different publications
and this is what i did here so here i
accounted i counted the proportion
of publications
mentioning western blood in the text
word you see on
the top
that you see here
normalized to all publications in the
protein field
and you see that in the 80s beginning of
the 80s there's a
strong increase of this proportion and
then it reached somehow a steady state
in panel a
um around 1990 until today where
western blood is
used in eight to ten percent of all
studies of all papers um of the protein
field and this is much higher than other
protein related techniques like mass
spectrometry in b eliza and c
immunohistochemistry in d or microscopy
in e
and
so i would conclude based on this data
that western blood is still the most
used protein analytical technique
on the world
however also this i would like to admit
very probably although
the most used technique it has
disappeared from
from the spotlight because as you see in
panel f the peak when you do the same
analysis
but now uh counting how often western
blood was mentioned in the title
then the peak was
around in the 90s around 1990 and then
it went back to quite low numbers so it
happened quite rarely that western plots
is the word term western blood is
mentioned in the title
which is different from mass
spectrometry for example it's more
modern and more fancy to use mass
spectrometry so
here it goes up to six per mill this
time not percent
so although it went out of the
focus the spotlight it's still the most
uh used technique western blood
and as you subscribe for this webinar
you all might have
done already with some bloods know how
it works but nevertheless i want to
spend at least this
first
slide this one slide
to sum up main
steps
so and you can also
try to find differences if you have used
already already the the technique of
protein simple
our host you can check where our
differences between the classical
western blot and
protein simple you always need i think
independent of the
of the methods you need a protein source
of course here in step one then you need
a protein
extraction
you should deter determine the
concentration this would be a part of
the extraction step
here to see how much you extract it then
in step three it would be a protein
separation here's a difference between
classical
western blood and protein simple um
because protein simple is using
capillaries also the transfer step
before it's not done uh in protein
simple but in the classical version it
is done so you transfer the protein to a
membrane
and then five it's a matter of
discussion if this is still a western
blot by definition or already the next
that the detection of antigens and there
you can use either as we do it um in our
group often we use serum from patients
for example to find auto antibodies but
most most people of you in the audience
might use commercial and purified
antibodies
um in order to
uh yes
make bands protein bands visible
so
one of the
uh first important question is why
actually do we need a loading control
and i want to show this to you to
explain it in simple in a simple way
is imagine here what we usually see in
publications in your
in your results probably you might
compare
different
conditions so let's say we have control
and the treatment
and our hypothesis and this is what we
also see here is that the level of our
protein of interest
increases
um upon the treatment
but if you have only these information
um a skeptical researcher should also
always be careful and say is this really
the case did our protein of interest
increase upon the treatment or can it
not be that we just
loaded much more protein here on the
right side at the treatment
lanes
to prove that to prove that you actually
have loaded the same amount of total
protein in in all of your lanes
you need some control usually it is done
with housekeeping proteins like tubulin
or axine for example
and this band this tubulin actin this
housekeeping protein is something like a
proxy
or um something like a marker for the
total protein that you loaded into the
lane you see here on the
left side now
what you usually do not see
because you loaded a lysate of cells or
lysate of tissues for example which
consists of many
proteins usually you do not see them but
they are there
so here you see that you have loaded
more or less the same quantity of total
protein of your lysates protein
concentration into all of the lane
so and yes and you use the housekeeping
protein as a as a proxy as an indicator
for this total protein
so in this case it's the optimal case we
do not have
um difference in our level of protein of
interest but we do
no sorry we also we do not have a
difference in our
total loading
in the
next
example we could see
what
the skeptical scientist was maybe also
expecting
that was advocate so here we see that
the nice
difference in our protein of interest
that we saw and what maybe according to
our hypothesis
is actually
not really convincing because
also the total
protein as you see on the left side
is much less so we just loaded into the
control we loaded much less
sample than in the treatment and this
has
caused
the difference in our protein levels we
nicely see it on our proxy on our
housekeeping protein which shows
what we have loaded actually
but
imagine now or let's uh yeah let's
continue with the question where
does actually unequal loading come from
so here i
simplified some of the
the steps where
that could be possible sources of
unequal loading and the first one is one
of the first uh steps of your protocol
usually it is there's a concentra the
determination of the concentration of
protein imagine you have your four
samples two replicates of a control and
two replicates of a treatment
and it's
five five and five microgram per
microliter but on the very
right sample you find nine
so a much higher concentration which of
course leads to the situation that you
load less protein to have the same
amount of total protein loaded this is
the goal but in reality
imagine there was a mistake in your
bc essay or bradford or whatever you did
in reality it was it was over five but
you thought it was nine so what you did
is you loaded
much less
because you thought it's a high
concentration so if you if you have
issues already in your concentration
determination step you will have an
unequal loading on your gel
another source
of unequal loading is unequal sample
pipetting where you lose sample i think
most of you will remember
their first
western blood i i do and i even more do
you remember students internship
students in our lab who did their first
western blood and what happened very
commonly
is so you load your sample you go into
the lane
and uh put the
very often
blue bluish
liquid into the lane and then at the
very end there is a bubble and the tip
of the cone is still too deep in the
solution and the bubble rises and pushes
out half of your soup so you lose
probably half of your sample
and
yeah this would be in
especially for beginners a source of
unequal loading
then the next source con
refers to the
transfer so far we were on the gel level
now the transfers or we transfer by
electro transfer for example the
proteins from the gel
to the membrane so now we are having our
bands on the membrane
and
imagine there was for example a big
bubble between gel and transfer or for
some other reasons there was the
electrical field was not homogeneous
and
now what is resulting is that the
transfer on the here on the right side
of the treatment side was
less efficient maybe even in one
specific part here in the middle part
and then in the worst case imagine your
protein of interest it has issues in the
transfer but your
housekeeping protein maybe is much lower
[Music]
and
does not show with difference so if you
do housekeeping
uh protein immunostaining it will look
nice
and you will see a significant
difference in your in your signal of
interest
but in reality
uh this was a technical issue
and you will not see it when you use a
housekeeping protein but you would see
it if you if it was somehow possible to
make
visible what you were actually loading
and transferring on your membrane
very similar
last
possible source i think there are more
but i mentioned here only
four is if you do stripping and want to
re-probe your membrane also while
stripping you always lose not only the
antibodies but also sometimes proteins
and this loss of proteins can also be
inhomogeneous and then it results in the
same effect as for inheritance transfer
so this would not be
yeah it's called source of unequal
loading it has the same it's not
actually the loading that is here the
problem is it's a transfer but it has
the same consequences
so i think from this we all agree that
we need something like a loading control
the question is rather the discussion is
what should it be and the traditional
solution is housekeeping proteins like
tubulin
because the general assumption is that
they are equally expressed this is what
you read quite often that they are
ubiquitous
um
that they are at the same level
independent if you compare young against
old or
i don't know green leafs of arabidopsis
against
flower leaves
yes so this is the theory equally
expressed but
unfortunately this uh this theory
is uh
not true so housekeeping problems are
not equally expressed
and i i could give a one lecture only
about examples of
research of people of college seeing in
which cases they found
housekeeping proteins unexpectedly to
show a difference in two conditions that
were compared
i do not do that i show only one
publication that convinced me when i was
still in my studies end of my studies
here from 2007 2008
it's a colleagues from czech republic in
the united states
and they found
they called it deja vu in proteomics so
already seen
and they they published the hit parade
of repeatedly
identified differentially expressed
proteins so they check different
studies from proteomics using mass
spectrometry for example where groups
have compared
anything old against young
brain region a against brain region b
and so on so
anything that they were not very strict
in in selecting they only wanted to know
which proteins do people find
and then they found these deja vu these
proteins that they strangely had already
seen before in the paper before who
would analyze something very different
and
so the list i show you here the top 15
of the most identified differentially
expressed proteins here the table for
the families grouped together and you
see that actines and tubulins depending
if you see take humans on the left
or studies that only address
rodents on the right
side
here between 20 20 and 30 percent of all
uh studies of all
comparisons between two conditions found
acting and or tubulins being different
significantly differentially expressed
so this means that
these families are not at all equally
expressed
which has an
impact strong impact for the choice of
loading controls for western blocks
so
another concern another issue with using
housekeeping protein proteins
um is that they are often highly
abundant which is quite nice to have
very clear signals but it is also a
disadvantage because here
an image i don't show the source uh
because it's not
the goal to blame someone i don't even
know it i think it's a here this i got
from from a colleague from twitter who
did an analysis of a saturation analysis
and he saw here on the right side that
there is
we call it a ceiling effect so usually
the center of a band
should be
more intensive than the periphery so it
should be more like a dome but here what
you see is that the center
and the derivative very flat which means
yeah it's the saturation there's a
ceiling effect and the consequence
unfortunately is that if you would load
now a bit more or with less would not
result in in differences if you are
if you're saturated if your signal is
already saturated
so
which scenarios could result
from from these issues
so we have already
talked about this best case scenario you
have a difference in your opportunity of
interest but no difference in your
loading control this is something what
you want
i want to see but imagine
the second case also this we have
already seen we think to have a
difference in our protein of interest in
red between control and treatment but in
reality we just did not load the same
amount of sample in the control versus
treatment lanes
so now it can get more complicated but
usually these cases are more
realistic
so
here
you see that unfortunately we are in one
of these 20 to 30 percent of cases where
your housekeeping protein is
regulated shows a difference and if this
by chance goes just in the other
direction as your protein of interest
then unfortunately you will
still have this is the same scenario as
in the slide before on the left side you
see that in the controls we loaded much
less than in the treatment by any
accident by any reason
but we do not see it if
the
housekeeping protein on the right side
in blue is either saturated that could
be one problem or it is
regulated just in the opposite direction
um yes then you would publish a very
nice significant
uh
difference which is actually that you
see on the left
um you know based on the technical issue
that you would have seen if you were
able to see what you loaded if you would
able to see the total protein on your
membrane
last scenario
although this happens quite often i read
in the internet often or hear from
colleagues you have a perfect scenario
on the left side what you often do not
see the total protein you see all is
fine
you loaded the same amount in control
and treatment but
your housekeeping protein on the right
that you chose
is
shows
is regulated in the same direction as
your protein of interest maybe they even
belong to the same family or
yeah
don't know so
they might be in this case they are
regulated in the same
uh different so you see
according to your hypothesis probably a
different in your difference in your
protein of interest however your
housekeeping protein is not equal and
this you cannot publish so your boss or
the reviewer or yourself in the best
case will say no
that's something strange i cannot i
cannot show this
so
these are not
cases that i invented they are
they really happen and in internet you
find hundreds of questions in scientific
discussion forums here i want to show
you six questions only the questions not
not possible answers just to show you
what is the reading world
um
yeah from researchgate in this case here
first one what are options for membrane
fraction loading control proteins for
western blood and he he or she they
don't want to use sodium potassium
atpase for any reason maybe it's on the
same level as of their protein of
interest
and these questions you can just
exchange
the word of the object so what is a good
loading control for and then you find
questions like arabidopsis or brain or
dinosaur bones or something like this so
you find the weirdest cases
here in the next one someone is
searching for and the good loading
control and secreted proteins
to the media and then the third one
i maybe it's my favorite because this
person is so close
to a solution and it's it's actually it
actually a good example of our last
scenario in this on my slide before so
what's the reasonable loading control
they are asking for nuclear protein and
acute injury
and
now
look here in the third row how and the
second how to explain
there's a typo i think that my total
protein of a specific signal pathways
almost the same
so all is fine he he or she they did a
total protein staining
they are almost the same but now the
housekeeping brought in the histone
varies from each other in treatment and
control for example
so this is one of these cases where all
is fine but you think you have a problem
because it's one of these 20 30 of cases
where the housekeeping protein is just
significantly regulated so you cannot
use this housekeeping protein but this
is the cool thing so close to the
solution because
they did already apparently a total
protein staining and saw that the total
protein they loaded the same so they had
a loading control they saw they loaded
the same but they didn't realize that
it's a very good loading control that
they had
which was not the housekeeping party
then
which are the best loading controls for
western blood excluding cytoskeleton
ones
which antibody should be used for
loading control
in western blood when cells are getting
bigger good point and she's writing or
he they i'm afraid but i'm normalized
with
tubulin something else
and if the cell is getting bigger after
treatment yeah maybe also the
housekeeping proteins are getting more
this is a very good point a realistic
fear
and
they are close to
the solution
last point is better acting a good
loading control in immunoblot for
apoptosis studies
now is it
used here probably abused it's another
question if it's a good
idea
idea to use it so the crucial question
is
and this
is important to understand
that what we what the community is
currently using is
housekeeping proteins that are a proxy
for what we really loaded on the child
for the toe for all brought in for the
total proteins on the left side that you
hear that is what you want to see you
want to have an
equal
loading of your the sample that you
loaded
so the question is why going this extra
way and why not just directly
making visible this total protein on
your trend on your membrane then you see
what you load and do not need a
some representative proxy a housekeeping
protein that might be completely off and
might be
not representative anymore for what you
really have loaded as we have seen in
the examples
and this has
been done already so i i'm i did not
invent that i i was not the first
person who suggested just staining the
total protein on your on your membrane
the only thing what i did
uh
three four years ago
was to collect
these uh few publications that have
already tested the total protein
staining and used and tested in western
blood as a total protein as a as a
loading control
and so far seven
[Music]
total protein stainings have been used
you see them here ponso s stain
techniques hyper ruby epicoconone based
stainings commercial middle plaque and
science five
for all of them there is at least one
publication that
uses and shows
benefits or parameters
when they used it as a loading control
in western blood
and so i i wrote a review publication
about this summarizing main parameters
and i'm quite
happy
that
this publication is appreciated so you
see i'm far away from
brunettes or tobin's
thousands of publications but it's also
not that long ago
um
yeah so
i
have around 20 citations per year which
is
uh clearly above the average of this
journal where this was
published and
so i'm quite happy and this happens
unfortunately rarely to a scientist that
you publish something and then you see
that really people
use it and have a positive
as a benefit for for the community this
is
always a nice feedback
and so in this publication in this
review you'll find many
data
which are i do not want to go to this
data it would be a relatively
boring presentation if i read you the
dynamic ranges
and the detection limits of each of the
staining for each of the publications
this is something which is not feasible
or doesn't make sense for presentation
because it it really strongly depends on
what you are doing in your lab which
sample which material you are working
with maybe you have very precious
material and can load only
one microgram per lane
and then you have to choose one that is
quite sensitive or you have other
restrictions and that's why i made this
huge table in this public in this review
to show for all of these seven
um
published
uh total protein stainings what are the
parameters when you use them as a
loading control in western blood and you
see it here first one is for ponso
you see it was it was the different
publications that's why in the first
column you see the dynamic range
which goes from
10 to 45 and another one five 520 so it
also strongly depends on what
the lab maybe the membrane maybe the
material you use
and so i do not go into these details i
only want that you understand the
different parameters and how and why
they are important
for the choice for the selection so we
have the dynamic range we have a
detection limit we have
a technical variation and then i want to
spend one slide about the variation
because
this is what
something that we tested for one of the
total protein staining the epicoconone
is a fungi
based compound
and just to show you what it means here
biological variation or technical
variation on the left side you see
biological variation
you see that we
did on the same blood we tested
the total protein staining on the top
then in a2 uh
beta tubulin and gap th and we tested
this over four
biological tissues for organs
actually
and you see it's even not that
surprising but it's still conflicting
with the hypothesis
of equal equally expressed housekeeping
proteins nature you see that the
housekeeping proteins are quite
different in your organs while the total
protein staining although the pattern is
also differing
but
if you take
all
you really want to see what you loaded
and take the whole
lane then the variation between the
organs is significantly less a3 panel
than for the
housekeeping proteins same for technical
variation
so here it's not different organs but
just different lanes to see the
technical variation over the lanes and
over here the total broadened standing
has benefits
compared to the
housekeeping brought in immunostaining
then the other points we saw in the
table is a dynamic range
and
a detection limit and so the the point
is if there is a loading difference our
loading control should be able to detect
it of course not simple but it's not
always that clear because imagine this
example is clear you might have
your your difference that we spoke about
before
but when your membrane if
your
membrane after the uh detection of the
signal looks like this this means
yeah maybe you had only one copy of
protein in the control and five copies
of the protein of interest and treatment
and you still have five times more you
have an
increase it's
a clear difference but if you
don't see it because five copies of a
molecule are not enough to make it
visible then you are below the detection
limit
same in the other direction
when you load
too much you are saturated we talked
about that before
and you also will have issues in
analyzing your data so in reality the
optimal situation should be somewhere in
between these two extreme cases and this
is what the dynamic range is
so you see it here again
simplified
seven lanes on the left side same for
the right side should be the same thing
only on the left side of the total
protein staining on the right side it's
an example for housekeeping protein
both
both of them have a detection
limit which is here in this case between
one and two at two we have
two microgram loading amount we still
have same bands
but nothing in one which means our
detection limit is two microgram and on
the other
extreme
between six and seven
you or we start between five and six we
still have increase in the signal but if
you load more if you load seven
microgram instead of six you loaded more
protein but you don't have more signals
so this means you have the ceiling
effect you reached the limit
which is um yeah and between this
between two and six you have the dynamic
range here in this example they would be
the same for load the total broaden
staining
and housekeeping protein but in reality
uh
many
of the cited publications in the table
show
that both detection limit and other
dynamic range are much better for total
protein staining than for housekeeping
proteins
so
i go back to the tables although i don't
go into detail so now then you
understand if you go through the table
and want to choose which total protein
staining fits best for you
you know
what it means so i did this here for
ponso staining
that was too fast
for
uh cyber ruby for comma c for needle
black
or stain free for epicoconone
and last but not least for sci-fi
some you see it here for this example
they didn't they tested for example a
dynamic range but not a detection limit
that's why there's no information
so there's still many
missing information
so something to do for for you for us
for the community
yeah so what i said i don't go into
details of this table but
i'm i'm a more visual person so here is
some main results of the table summarize
it's all studies
among above the seven total brought in
staining
that did analyses regarding the dynamic
range
and you see here for a posso s for
example there are four different studies
they are all a bit in the same range
we are showing
some
that the dynamic range is around 10
sometimes onto 200 micrograms of total
protein and when you see at the
extremities that the arrow had
that means that the authors did not
go through the limits so they did not
here for example opposed to s
uh reference 21 or the 43 it is i think
it was logarithmic so 5
microgram
and there was still a signal and when
they went lower no they didn't test it
so 5'4 there was still a signal but they
didn't
try to find the limit which was
different for cyber ruby and comma c for
example here there's no arrow head that
is the end of the line
reference 40 and here you see that one
microgram of total protein was the last
step that still was visible visible if
you load less then you lose the signal
so you have a detection limit and this
can be helpful if you want to load very
small amounts then you should
choose your
um total protein staining accordingly
and wisely or this you see here in the
blue box or test other ranges if they
have not been tested yet the same
applies for housekeeping proteins so if
you insist in doing housekeeping
proteins then even then you should
test
and even publish it
showing that you are still in the
dynamic range that it's not saturated
and yeah at all is fine
so
there are still some proteins total
burning stainings that are maybe in the
pipeline so these are possible total
protein stainings that could be used as
loading controls you see here a list of
known and accepted total protein
stainings but they have not yet been
tested as a loading control in western
plus
that's why they are not in the same
table as the other candidates but
there's still space you see you can make
a new publication
we could make a cooperation
if we find the time and test
some
of these candidates
as a as a novel
loading control at the end
i would like to
refer to the protein simple system
because also here you can use
that the advantages of total gradient
staining the brady and simple system we
have quickly talked already in a slide
before it is quite close to western
blood i don't know the current
definition if it's
just
you the audience would like to call it
an
a nice simplified way of western blood
or if it's another category for you it's
like a small semantic discussion it's
also not very interesting how we call it
but actually the steps are quite close
to it because you have the loading
you load your sample this is an
important step that you also have in
traditional western blood
you separate the protein you immobilize
it and then you have the
detection with antibodies in the very
left column you can use a
cumulative no i hope you are in this
case a horseradish peroxidase label
secondary antibodies you can use cumin
luminescence signal you can use
antibodies that are and
that have a
fluorophore in the second dairy antibody
then you can use the fluorescence to
detect the signal
you can and this is on the right column
here also replex
here the first
part is the same as in the middle
just what you do at the end is you can
do
stripping can get rid of the antibodies
before and can
add another antibody or what you can
also do
is um to use a total protein stain and
this has
also have already been done and tested
for the protein simple system you see
here
an
internal example of protein
simple
in b you see you see the quantification
of the of a of the left side but the
interesting part is actually the panel a
where you see
um some antibody against it's a
phosphophosphorylation specific antibody
and this is a quite nice example because
you have actually two loading controls
you could even use the pen
ax antibody as a loading control because
you see
the second and the fourth lane they are
not
empty which you could
which you could be devil's advocate and
and say if you see only the these nice
signals in the first and third uh
columns but you see first from the red
signal but also from the total protein
signal that you actually that you really
have loaded the same
amount of sample
and the last example
i think is my favorite because this is
how a total protein
loading control should be tested for
because here on the top
left
you see that what was done here is
you really provoked
some loading differences you see here
different loading difference on the very
right is 0.2 and then on the very left
it's 20 times less
you see it in blue in the total protein
staining but you see it also in black
and your your signal of interest
and imagine now
there was an issue in the loading and
you have you loaded much less
but this is not a problem if you
normalize if you are arithmetically
normalize
your signal with what you have actually
loaded and this is done in the panel top
right in the orange bars you see
normalized
and then even if you load
different
total amounts
by
accident or by intention as cto was done
here then it is not a big problem
because if you normalize with what you
actually have loaded then you do not see
a difference and if you take only the
the raw data as shown in the blue bars
then you see of course clear differences
and if you do this
by accident you see differences that do
not reflect your biological question but
more a technical
issue
so
this
is
the
yeah
the end and i want to end again because
i started with like a fun fact and last
week when you we me received the
invitation
i saw this in the subject and
i would i i
copied it into my presentation because
it is
something that
we can do we can see what we learned it
can be one of the take home messages
because
i think it's not loading control versus
total protein staining i think and i
think
i hope this is something uh what you
learned from this talk is that the total
protein staining can be an example
for a total
loading control it can even be a better
loading control than our classical
loading controls
and another
fun fact at the end if you want to and
still insist in using housekeeping
proteins as learning controls
i'm fine with it i cannot change it
and but maybe you have the same uh
reason
uh for keeping housekeeping proteins
like this colleague here that i copied
this
sentence from twitter the lodi control
can truly be the best supporting actor
in the western lodging world sometimes
when gazing at a plot that leaves me
filled with frustration and confusion
all i can do
is walk away and say at least the actine
is beautiful
so i think this is a
yeah maybe one of the reasons to keep
housekeeping proteins but scientifically
not the best
so i hope what you learned some main
take home messages
was that western blotting is not
outdated
um in any form so neither in the
traditional form nor in some
perfectionized version
of a
protein simple for example
then housekeeping proteins are
neither locally nor temporarily
equally stably expressed so not at least
not necessarily there are examples of of
course where they are but in too many
cases they are not equally expressed
and total brought in stainings
as uh loading control in western blood
has multiple advantages over
housekeeping projects
so i'm
open for questions thank you for for
listening to me and yes i'm looking
forward to discussing
these uh topics
now with you in the question answer
session thank you very much
thank you dr morris for your informative
presentation we'll now start the live q
a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is
would staining with tubulin be an
accurate way to prove loading quality
when trying to measure protein expressed
into conditioned media
um
i see yeah this sounds like one of these
very specific questions one of these
examples that i
just told you from researchgate
so i understand the question asks what
if i do research in proteins that are
released to the medium and i want to
make western blots with the medium to
find there some
protein of interest so can i use tubulin
and it's a good example because it shows
that
we we do not know so we is we must find
out is tubulin
really released to the medium in the
first
moment i would say
no maybe not so it would not be a good
idea but it shows that we don't know so
either we would need to do the extra
work
and and find it out and look is it
strong enough the signal and is it
stable is it
equally expressed between the conditions
or that would be the alternative to just
use uh
one of the total rotten stainings
as an alternative
all right thank you
next question
what about staining the spent gel rather
than the membrane
yeah that's a that's a good question i
am i addressed this point in my review
article but i didn't mention it now in
my my presentation
and this is something that is also
sometimes
recommended
and
you remember my slide where i was
talking about the possible sources of
unequal loading
and doing the broader loading uh
control total problem staining on the
level of the gel would control
for the sort for the first two sources
which was the
issue in the concentration um
determination
uh and also the loading itself that we
would perfectly uh control uh with a
total broad in staining on the shell
level but we would not
see any issues that come
through the
transfer or later by stripping for
example so it's
partly it helps but not everything so i
prefer
um the total protein staining on the
membrane level because it covers also
the transfer that is an important step
all right thank you
our next
attendee first says awesome talk thank
you and their question is for
inhomogeneous transfer
how would you address that issue
uh yeah so i understand this question so
not not how to to control it or to find
it so then the next step if
if we see the
uh unequal transfer
so
if one student would ask me that i would
say
repeat the western blot and if it's
continuously
the right side less
transfer than the left side for example
then there might be some some issues in
the in this in the setting maybe then
you check should check all the
the cables or something like this
because i think this should not come
through the through the buffer because
if everything is fine this
should be equal yeah so this is really
difficult to
to answer because it could be so much so
i would just repeat it maybe you have a
second uh
setup and or tried in
another floor with a neighbor group then
you can rule out if it is the material
or rather the buffer or something like
this
all right thank you
next question may i know why i see big
differences
in total protein signal
across different organ or tissue
even
i had quantify and loaded equal amount
of protein
yeah this is uh would be surprising to
me i also um did something similar and
even uh was provoking seeing differences
diluted by
checking different organs
and what i what i showed on one slide
was that the pattern is indeed very
different so some bands are very strong
in one organ but not in the other
but then when i um when i checked
for the
for the volume the total signal over the
lane that was quite similar so that
should be the case so it's not a problem
as the pattern is different this is
normal between organs but the intensity
should be the same if this is not the
same then yeah either there's an issue
with the
the quantification with the bradford or
something like this that for some organ
specific proteins it works better or
worse
or um in some organs maybe
highly abundant or hydrophobic proteins
are over represented
and then they might be
lost during the transfer
so this could these could be reasons why
um you see
uh differences even in the total protein
staining that the
that the numbers are not representative
more either that hydrophobic proteins
that could be in that could be an
explanation
okay thank you um it looks like we have
time for one more question
what if a reviewer asks me to use a
classical housekeeping protein as a
loading control
yeah i think that happens
quite often i hear other from colleagues
and
so what i usually say is
the reviewer is a scientist so and we
scientists should be
best convinced
by
by data so what one could do is
just to cite
uh one of the publications showing that
this type of total brought in training
um
is
is a good one or
yes or the review article to show that
it is more and more getting standard uh
to use total protein staining
and yeah that would be the the way i
would try uh to convince the reviewer
all right thank you dr moritz do you
have any final comments for our audience
just thank you for listening and uh yeah
it was a pleasure for me and um
uh yeah sorry there's so few time was
left for the questions but feel free to
contact me and i also i think that
questions that have not been responded
and that come later i will receive by
email and i will help you too to get in
contact with you thank you for listening
well thank you again dr moritz for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor protein simple for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand laboratories
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye